you seem like a cool person tell us a
little bit about yourself what do you do
so what I do for a living is I am an art
director at a slime company so we Mass
produce slime uh for people who are
really into collecting slime okay uh now
I know slime is a thing kids love these
days they love their slime M and and
when you say you mass-produce it meaning
what does it come in what is the is is
the Slime sold in stores that you that
you make so we don't do as much
wholesale slime we primarily sell from
our personal website but we make all of
the slime in the warehouse but it's what
you're talking about is a bespoke slime
artisanal slime artisinal slim designer
slime yeah yeah an artisinal slime
exactly so this isn't just some goop
that would drop on someone on a
Nickelodeon show this is really this is
the really good stuff this is the real
deal this is like very it's very
complicated I didn't know anything about
slime until I got this job and I know
more about slime than I ever wanted to
know in my life so well I have lots of
wisdom to I know well good because I
don't know anything about slime other
than it's slimy but I don't know
anything what is slime composed of
primarily so slime is primarily made of
glue water and borax uh those are kind
of your base components but depending on
what type of glue you use or what kind
of addin you put in it you can get a lot
of very different textures so we have
slimes that are clear we have slimes
that are more opaque we have some that
are crunchy uh there are a lot
it's so many things you can do okay um
so first of all is there such thing as
like a a slime somaler someone who can
boy yeah a slime Aller someone who can
open up the package and feel it and go
ah yes yes I see what they've done
they've used a borax uh from the Tampa
area and I'm
sensing I'm sensing a glue that's more
of a resin I detect that it's uh from
the northern Canadian woods yeah or is
there like a vintage to slime yeah in a
weird way yes to both of those questions
um I have kind of myself become a slime
simaler because we need to figure out
like different types of glue make
different types of textur so like a wood
glue is going to give you a different
slime than a school glue clear glue is
Sor Pat but of course of course I mean
this is just insulting you're not
speaking to idiots here yeah what I mean
you think we were you think we were born
yesterday um so and what is the Slime
that you uh create that you sell what
does it come in does it come in an an
egg does it come in a a plastic Bowl I'm
over enunciating for no reason what is
it coming no it was really good it was
really good I can show you I have a
bunch of slimes over here of course you
do yes you're in your room and that's
where you keep sliming what do people do
with slim well hold on one thing at a
time
that's a valid question I want to know
son you probably noticed that Envy can
actually be a motivating force that
inspires people it could I guess like
you probably come in every day and look
at me and go wow I envy being con
O'Brien not at all not even in the
slightest the looks the talent that head
of hair nity dopy Envy is commonly
regarded as a vice but it can be a good
thing Envy can be a catalyst for
creation inspiring the world to raise
the bar and Angel's Envy is a bourbon
that is worth the Envy okay so that's
where we're going with this that's where
it ended up I was wondering where you
were going you right ahead I would have
known Angel's Envy is finished in Port
barrels that's the key which adds a
layer of complexity to the whiskey and
gives it a unique and approachable
flavor whether it's for someone special
or to bring to a housewarming party
Angels Envy makes the perfect gift with
its unique bottle design Angels Envy
bourbon finished in Port barrels is sure
to be the Envy of any bar cart 2 look
for Angels Envy bourbon finished and
Port barrels please drink responsibly
copyright 20 24 Angel's Envy bottle by
Louisville Distilling Company Louisville
Kentucky I love fielding all of these
questions about slime uh this is the
container it's just like a little cute
like plastic container with like a lid
on it try to keep it airtight in there
um we also do Clays like we do clay
toppers for the Slime so like this is a
deli container that we put a little like
clay toast in there's a lot to we do a
lot of different things a clay a toast
that's made of clay I to show you this
okay you are dealing with idiots here so
yeah I don't I don't know why why would
you have toast made of clay and slime
goes on top of it what is that what what
do you accomplishing there so basically
you can kind of make like a DIY kit so
like this is a honey toast DIY kit so
you can kind of see this like cute
little like clay that looks like a toast
yes oh and then you spread the then you
spread the slime on it yeah you kind of
like put it on top of the base slime and
then you put this little honey like
syrup on top of it and kind of like
drizzle it so you're pretending to make
a food item but nothing is edible yes
exactly nothing is edible that's why we
have to put do not eat on all of our
labels I love that you're making pretend
toast and pretend honey for children and
then saying just don't eat it that's
fantastic Prett much oh we made a
tricycle what's it made of
explosives better not get on that
tricycle you'll blow up it looks so cool
I know we call it a tricycle just to
confuse kids hope they don't get on
it I don't know Patty I'm really
concerned you would be surprised by the
amount of uh there are also a lot of
it's not just kids that buy the product
it's actually a lot of like people in
their 20s and like kind of young adults
and older people who just like they like
the kind of texture of the Slime and it
kind of becomes like a like a comfort
also is it is it all about like holding
the Slime and and you squeeze it it
gloops through your fingers yes very
much so it's like very like Vis look at
that yeah that is pleasing it's pretty
good uh this one is not from the company
that I work for but it's a it's it's
basically like a tide slime like it
smells like laundry detergent uh and it
kind of looks like ti do you think
people uh use this uh does anyone ever
is there it do they bone it yeah is
there ever talk is there ever talk in
the industry about
people pleasuring themselves or having
having an erotic adventure with the
Slime was so hard for me not to make
this sexual I'm glad I'm not the one
that took us down that path we were all
thinking it but I always am the one who
take but is it okay Patty to talk about
this actually I'm qualified for this
yeah it's uh listen we I'll say this we
do not make slime for those purposes if
there is someone out there who does that
right I am not aware of them but like
shout out to them I guess if yeah I mean
penous magazine was basically for the
articles I notic you can't believe
people are looking at these new listen
all I'm saying is that uh it it comes to
mind that this uh that people are
it well notice there's say that
there's a do not eat label on there but
not a do not saying well I didn't
bring this there I was trying not to go
go there no I in no way I appreciate you
for not trying to go there I really see
that I respect that patty patty just to
be clear I would like to distance myself
from my friends I wasn't talking about
someone having intercourse with the
Slime oh I was thinking of someone um
spreading it over their body sexually
sexually okay uh for the to themselves
and yeah and maybe maybe immersing them
maybe immersing themselves in a tub of
it and just wriggling around and
[Music]
going your more of a romantic angle like
a Valentine's Day kind of bath of slime
with candles yeah I wasn't nothing
there's no uh you guys are being very
crass about this what I was thinking
about was scented candles and then a big
tub of slime and then little rose petals
on top of the Slime and then you get it
and blch
glur we have here is a round of
Mary kill with
slime
yeah I want to I want I want to marry
the SL take it out to dinner you want to
go to dinner with slime and the Slime
will have the beef please what's your
first date with slime like what movie
are you and slime going to see well I'm
sure we're going to
go see Ghostbusters yeah very good I'm
going to see vintage
Ghostbusters